All right.
Steve Krawczyk, how are you doing?
Oh, great, great, Michael.
Wonderful to have you here.
How are you?
Good.
So, you're talking
from Silicon Valley now?
Yes, at Palo Alto.
Okay. So, right across the street.
Wonderful. But you're originally from,
actually in New York, from the East Coast.
Yeah. Originally from Poland.
But I got to the United States
when I was six.
So, essentially I grew up here.
Spent time growing up in New York.
I went to school there.
And then, when college,
I happened to I ended up
at University of Michigan in Ann Arbor.
And it has happened for nine years
and that's a little bit of a story.
So, Let's start over there.
Spending nine years
at University of Michigan.
Right. So, I was pretty early on,
I was  fascinated by chemistry
and especially medicinal chemistry.
How pharmaceuticals work
and things like that.
And so, I wanted to study
medicinal chemistry.
And there aren't
that many medicinal chemistry programs
in the country.
A really good one was
at the University of Michigan.
At the College of Pharmacy.
And it actually turned out to be
an incredible stroke of luck for me
to go there.
So, it was kind of interesting story.
I applied to a variety of schools.
Michigan ended up being my first choice.
I ended up going up there.
I got a work study job stipend.
And so, my first week on campus there
as an undergrad,
I went to the office look for jobs, I go,
"Oh, wow. Look, a lab assistant
at the College of Pharmacy."
"Perfect."
So, I go there Friday afternoon
and I meet the guy there and he says,
"Well, it's really cleaning rat cages
and that job is already taken. Sorry."
But he introduced me to this woman
who is doing like cell culture, biology,
drug testing and cell culture.
"I want you to go meet Linda."
So, he took me upstairs to introduce me
to this postdoc researcher,
Linda [--].
And she talk to me
about what I like to do,
what I'm interested in.
And she goes,
"Well, I mean,
this is like cell culture stuff."
"I'm not sure
you'd be really interested in that."
So, she said,
"Well, let me introduce you
to this guy over here."
And this was already Friday, like 5:30.
So, I go in and just kind of the old days
where this guy's in his office
smoking cigars,
and turned out to be the chairman
of the Department of Medicinal Chemistry.
And he said,
"Okay. Tell me about yourself."
I go in the spiel and then, he says,
"Well, we didn't have any openings."
"But tell me more."
So, I keep on talking.
And then he just starts making
like he's ready to threw me out of office.
And then I go,
"Oh, by the way, what about the job?"
And he goes,
"Oh, yeah, you can start next month."
So, this is just one of those stories
where I just I was in the right place.
And you could say it's luck.
But I did my research
and I was at the right place.
And Friday afternoon
maybe wasn't the right time,
but maybe it was.
Because it showed that the people
that were still there,
were really passionate about their job.
And they would recognize
that same passion in me.
So, it's not really a coincidence.
It wasn't planned out.
But when I look back with hindsight.
So, fast forward,
I started working in the lab
first, like washing dishes.
And, of course, just like
one of these Zen books,
the first thing he did,
he showed me this incredibly messy lab
and he said,
"Okay, I want you to clean this up."
And of course, I was really excited.
And I cleaned it up really really great.
And he came back really impressed.
So, I ended up helping
this graduate student
that was struggling a little bit.
But basically he decided,
"Okay, let's give this guy a helper
and you can help wash dishes
or set up reactions
and just learn basically."
So, basically, I was very lucky
to start working at the lab
as an undergrad my first week there.
And then fast forward, three years later,
it's time to figure out
what I'm going to do.
I just did not really feel ready
to go out in the workforce.
I want to get my graduate degree.
So, I ended up applied
for the graduate program there.
Got accepted now.
Before I was helping a graduate student,
now, I was a graduate student there.
And I attend my PhD
in medicinal chemistry five years later.
Why medicinal chemistry?
So, what was fascinating to you
in medicinal chemistry?
Just looking at books
and how the original medicinal chemistry,
all the drugs came from plants,
morphine, belladonna, strychnine,
reserpine was the first anti-hypertensive.
It was isolated from plan.
It turned out actually,
it caused depression.
So, I was just fascinated
how things cause the different actions.
Of course, we've got some
of the amphetamines,
which are the original antidepressants.
They caused high blood pressure.
So, you have just very interesting.
it's just fascinating to me
just looking at the structures.
How the similar structures
had similar activities
or sometimes similar structures
have very different activities.
It was all fascinating.
So, I want to get into that.
And just be able to make, cure stuff.
So, talk to me about the transition
from medicinal chemistry
on the East Coast now to Silicon Valley.
Right. So, that was
another interesting thing.
So, actually, during my grad students
after I finished my masters,
I always want to go to California.
To Silicon Valley.
Even back when I was in New York.
I didn't even know what Silicon Valley was
I thought it was like this place.
I didn't realize it was really
a construct.
So, paint me the picture.
Because now it's very obvious why
a lot of people flock to the Bay Area.
Well, in 2020, a lot of people
flock out to the Bay Area.
But until now,
a lot of people flock in here.
And why back then,
when it's less of a big bubble
and it's a worldwide problem?
Because I think especially,
my dad was electronics engineer
and then I see Silicon Valley
got started in silicon.
In silicon. Right.
Yeah. So, I had a hankering
for getting out here.
So, a back of the story,
it was interesting.
And when I finished my Masters in 1986,
I said, "Maybe I can get out here now."
So, I applied to UCSF.
There's initial chemistry program there
for the PhD.
I got in. I came out here to visit
and I got off the plane at the tarmac.
At that point, the SFO
we actually we brought up a staircase.
Like the fresh air was just incredible.
I mean, basically, I flew out of Detroit
when I was in Ann Arbor.
And that was before admission.
So, California was the first
to have the car emission.
And so, it was like night and day.
I love this place.
They had some day of events
for the incoming potential students.
And I said,
"Oh, I really want to stay here."
But as a grad student,
I couldn't really enjoy it
because I didn't have much money.
And this in the lab.
And the guy back there
really helped me out
by giving me that job.
So, I'll stay.
So, anyway, I ended up staying
for another three years.
And then the interesting point is that,
what happened is that
when it was time to graduate,
I started looking around for postdocs.
And there was this guy,
I saw a postdoc position
at Caltech for Peter Dervan.
A very very high level guy in that field.
And I wrote up a proposal
for antisense DNA.
At that point,
I didn't even realize it was a thing
but I figured it would be cool.
Because I studied nucleoside.
So, if you string these along,
you could actually make like a code
and actually selectively block genes.
So, I wrote up a proposal to him.
I didn't get in there. Okay, whatever.
So, fast forward.
A couple of months, my boss comes back
from a meeting in California, says,
"Hey, I met this guy."
"You might be interested
in getting a job there."
"It's a company called Gilead Sciences."
"And they're doing antisense."
I go, "Oh wow. Great."
"This is what I wanted to do."
So, it's a 30 person startup
at this point in Foster City.
I go there and it's just great.
And I ace the interview.
I get the position.
And guess who's on the board of advisers?
Peter Dervan.
So, this is what I'm getting back to you.
You end up in the same place.
Because, well, you just do.
Because you just naturally fit there.
Right. Well, it sounds like,
on one hand, you're saying
you come back to the same place.
On the other hand,
a theme that I'm picking up here
throughout your experiences is that
you're very open to these opportunities.
You're taking that Friday afternoon meeting
and you're getting excited
about this idea of cleaning a lab
and doing to the best of your abilities.
You're excited about accepting a job offer
in Foster City with a 30 person startup.
So, things are aligning.
But it's not just by chance.
It sounds like,
because you're you're actively looking
for these opportunities
and harnessing them, right?
Yeah. So, I hate to say I actively looking
because sometimes like
I'm afraid, a little bit more passive.
But I always try to place myself
in places where these opportunities
are just there.
And then it come to me.
Because it's a little bit more natural
if you try to, you're pining for stuff.
I mean, some people can pull it off.
The J-Ventures people
are just a great bunch
and they're go getters and they can do it.
So, I compensate by just trying to be
in the right place at the right time.
Wonderful. Wonderful.
Yeah. So, there I am with Peter Dervan
and then working side by side
with a former postdoc office.
So, I would have ended up there anyway.
If I had gotten that postdoc,
I would have ended up at Gilead anyway.
So, just like that. It's pretty funny.
And then, of course,
if you go forward 25 years
that I spent there,
it ended up to be a fortune,
a hundred billion dollar company.
Wow.
And almost went bankrupt
a couple of times in its early days.
So, you're joining a 30 person startup
with somebody on the board
who you hope to do a postdoc with
and you end up doing similar work
within the company.
Fast forward 25 years
and that small startup in Foster City
that somebody told you about
is a hundred billion dollar company.
Right. And then, yeah.
So, the other funny thing is that,
so, during there I ended up transitioning
from medicinal chemistry at the bench,
leading a discovery group
and then getting drafted
into the patent office.
Into the patent department there.
Because as the pharma business
is all about really patents.
The patent side of thing.
And Gilead's idea there
was to mind the patent landscapes
of other people's patents.
To figure out what to do.
And then you have to design around, right?
Because you have some other company
has a great molecule,
but you want to make something better.
But they have a patent
on all this broad classes of molecules.
You have to, as a chemist to figure out,
okay, what's going to be active,
but not going to be dominated
by their patent.
Can we spend just two, three minutes
talking about why patents
in pharma and medicine,
why is it such an important thing?
Because for me,
and for a lot of other people
who are not coming in from this industry,
when we were building software
as a service, it's very hard to patent
as far as I understand.
But it sounds like in the field
that you were working in for many years,
it's mandatory.
So, talk to me a little bit
about this landscape of IP and patents
in medicine.
That's perfect.
So, we have a lot of clients
that do software as a service.
And I say, great.
Well, sometimes it's the combination
of a device that sends data
and then it gets process server side.
So, I tell them,
"Look, the device,
you have to file a patent on it."
"You have to disclose everything
that's in the device."
"Because if it's really valuable,
someone's going to open it up,
reverse engineer it."
I mean, there are out for stuff there
that take apart semiconductors.
They slice through silicon.
They do electron microscopy.
They think they can figure out
what you're wrong is
by looking at it
and figure out what the code
you can get code out.
So, everything that's
in the customer's hands
has to have a patent on it.
Server side, so yes, it's great,
because people can't really figure out
what you're doing.
So, you don't need to patent that.
And it's tough under our patent system
to patent software and stuff.
But it's good.
You just keep it server side
and you're fine.
With pharma, though, it's really the idea
that a certain molecule
can treat a particular disease
is its intellectual property, right?
Because once that information is out,
and information wants to be free,
anyone in India,
anywhere, Africa, Brazil,
can go in the lab make that molecule.
Right?
And it's not like you're the only one
that can make the molecule.
And you're the only one
who can be the single source.
Because with today's chemical technology,
if you give me a sample,
I can tell you what it is exactly
the structure of molecule usually,
within a couple hours
using this modern instrumentation we have.
And then, just given the chemical knowledge
accrued over the centuries,
we can go in the lab
and probably make that.
Within a month we can have
a pretty good synthesis of it.
So, I can go to pharmacy,
buy a pill, analyze it,
send it over to a contractor,
basically make duplicates very very quickly.
That's why you need a patent.
If someone has a weird
machine learning algorithm that's adaptive
and it's sitting in a server,
in their vault, whatever secure room,
it's kind of hard to figure out
how that works.
Although there are some theories
that you can.
But besides that, in pharma
it's about that molecule, right?
I mean, and the beauty of pharma is that,
people complain about the patent system,
but once the patents expire,
the system works like it's supposed to,
then anyone,
then that information is free.
Anyone can make that molecule.
There's regulatory issues.
So, that's why the value.
I mean, we're giving them this monopoly
for whatever, an average is about 12 years.
11 to 12 years.
It's supposed to be 20.
But it's on average, it ends up,
because of delays, ends up 11, 12 years.
And then later on,
the molecules are there for anyone.
So, I think that's what makes the system
really great.
And that's why patenting
is very important.
People say, pharma doesn't spend
that much money on research.
But to me, it's like, okay,
your brain doesn't use
all your body's energy, right?
But yeah, but if you don't have your body,
your brain can't work.
So, to me, it's like a pharma is,
80% of our budget is really
research and development.
Because you can't have research
and development if you don't have sales.
Doctors are pretty conservative.
Some people complain about
pharmaceutical advertising.
But on the flip side,
it takes a long time for,
I mean, look at the HIV drugs
Gilead developed.
It took a really long time for them
to really permeate the market.
And they're just like the best,
made incredible changes
in the lives of people,
people suffering with HIV.
Turning into a death sentence,
into a chronic disease.
And it's still took years
in order for the medical community
to really adapt to these things.
Just talking about PrEP,
which is the prophylaxis.
I mean, that would have been obvious
right at the start,
but we have to wait 20 years
before PrEP became a thing.
So, I think pharma does get a bad rap.
There are some bad pharma does
that do get to give them bad rap
or overall, I think,
you can't really say it's all that bad.
Right.
Every day [--]
eventually be free.
I'd love to spend the last few minutes
that we have talking a little bit
about your role as what you describe
as an emotional support angel.
I got a chance to talk
to quite a few angel investors,
especially here in the Silicon Valley.
And I've yet to hear the term
emotional support angel,
and I just love it.
So, talk to me a little bit
about what it means to you
to be an emotional support angel.
And you're investing in general
for both privately and in J-Ventures.
But let's start
with the emotional support side of it.
Right. So, I said
entrepreneurs have to think
they can walk through walls.
So, I'll give you an example.
So, the CEO was raising money.
She found a VC like,
a VC/angel type organization.
Basically told the GP what she needs.
And he wanted a reference.
So, she sent him my name
and I'm talking with him and he's asking,
"Oh, can she be a CEO?"
And I go,
"Yeah, she has this team already."
"She knows what she has to delegate
and what not."
"Just incredibly intense."
And he says,
"Okay, well, can I just confide in you."
"I mean, she told me
she can raise $10,000,000 this year."
"I mean, revenue."
"Do you think that's true?"
I just started laughing. I say,
"No. No way."
And he started laughing.
And he invested anyway. Right.
So, that's part of it.
And then, having telling the entrepreneur,
the CEO saying,
Well, look, it's good you were so intense,
you were really positive and optimistic
you could get that.
But at the same time,
you have to understand that not everyone,
it is an aspirational goal.
So, just telling maybe not everyone
would have that same response.
Some GPs will say,
"Oh, she can't? Okay. Forget it." Right?
But just following her. Yeah.
And then the other questions are,
they come back to me, says,
"Oh, was he really doubting my ability
as a CEO and stuff?"
And I go,
"Oh no, he's got to ask these questions."
So, just try to calm everything down.
And a lot of times these CEOs,
they just need to talk.
Right.
That's something that,
as a young entrepreneur,
you grow up
reading TechCrunch and Crunchbase.
Of our judgment,
because just when they're talking to you,
they're hearing themselves talk, right.
When you got that psychiatrists
and now the mental health people
and mental wellness people talk about
what's called a default mode network.
It's a voice in our head that keeps on
ruminating and going and thought loops
and doing stuff like that.
So, when you're an entrepreneur,
it's very easy to get into that, right?
You think,
"Oh, what do they think of me?"
Because you know
you're always on display.
You're always performing.
You're always questioning
how the audience is receiving you.
So, it's very easy to get into that
when you're talking to yourself.
It just sounds a lot different
than when you're saying the same thing
to someone else.
So, just being someone
that they can trust.
To just to basically listen
and not be judgmental
and keep thing in confidence.
I think that's important.
So, going back,
the reason I did tell that GP
that in my own opinion,
I didn't think she was going to be able
to get 10 million in 2020,
now, it still might happen,
so, I told him it might happen.
But I was confident in telling him
that I didn't think she could just because
I sensed that he didn't believe it.
So, I already knew.
I mean, if I thought
that he really thought she could
and just was kind of making sure,
I probably would have demurred,
figured out some way to weasel out
of answering that question.
But [--]
It's a very interesting balance
that you're playing here.
On one hand, you have stake in the company
and you have a stake
in the success of the company.
And part of the success
is also the company's ability
and the founder's ability
to continue raising the funds.
And the other hand, you are somewhat also
of a psychiatrist and the best friend
and a mentor and an investor to the founder.
Right. Yes.
And emotional support angel.
Right. So, yeah.
So, I pretty much knew the guy knew,
he was convinced she couldn't.
But I think the reason he ended up
did putting in the money
is because she was so confident.
So, I think better way of saying
she was confident
that she had a shot at it.
And I think that's really,
if you're doing anything with startups,
it's all about the shot on goal.
Because, I mean, all things can happen.
You just you don't know.
So, it's about, is it a good shot on goal?
And I think a lot of VCs might,
they want to see free money.
They want to see money just sitting there
and pick it up always.
Oh, you want to subscribe a round?
Okay. Yeah, I want in. Right?
But so, I mean,
and so this other of J-Ventures,
this guy was pitching.
He claimed to have discovered
room temperature superconductivity.
And so, being an IP expert,
I took a look at his patents.
The application he had.
He was about to have an allowance
and it looked really good.
There was some technical issues
that even though, yes,
room temperature superconductivity,
it was still not clear
how you're going to commercialize it.
What's the best way to commercialize it.
And J-Ventures pass
just because they weren't,
they had to help the guy
with his PowerPoint,
but they just weren't sure
if it was going to be a big investor
coming in.
They can put in some money.
He had a family office coming in
and he was good.
He was open to getting operating guy
or even a CFO that could pitch.
So, that was all good.
That wasn't really a problem.
But they just,
always are going to be someone,
a big investor.
Well, I think you're touching upon
one thing that we didn't have time
to talk too much about.
But that's not a risk.
That the more you risk.
But I think that it is incredible that
as both as a private angel
and emotional support angel,
but also part of J-Ventures,
this ability to bring in a community
where all of a sudden
we have an opportunity
where we have Steve here who is an expert,
or is able to go and dig deep into this IP
and validate the technology.
I think that's something that really
when you have almost 200 people
that are involved with the fund,
that's something that incredible
that can happen.
But Steve, unfortunately,
we do have to end here.
But I do have to ask my favorite question,
which is three words that you would use
to describe yourself
Just the ever optimist, I think.
The ever optimist.
I love it. I love it.
Steve, thank you very much. Toda raba.
And I definitely look forward
to maintaining this relationship
and bringing some ideas to you as well.
All right. Thanks, Michael.
Thanks for the opportunity.
Okay.